einen schönen guten abend zdf heute live
ja gut zwei wochen vor der
bundestagswahl und das ist auch unser
thema an diesem abend wie stehen die
parteien da wie ist ja momentan der
stand der dinge wir haben gesehen die
union befindet sich in den letzten
wochen in einem umfragetief auch damit
werden uns natürlich beschäftigen wie
gedenkt sie da raus zu kommen was machen
die anderen parteien wir sprechen gleich
mit dem politikwissenschaftler und
wahlforscher thorsten faas von der fu
berlin und in wenigen minuten gleich mit
manfred weber von der csu
fraktionsvorsitzender der fdp im
europäischen parlament und wir
diskutieren natürlich gerne wieder mit
euch fragen und kommentare wie immer an
uns gerne so zunächst aber begrüße ich
professor thorsten faas von der fau
berlin einen schönen guten abend an sie
und wir gehen direkt in medias res wir
schauen direkt auf die aktuelle
sonntagsfrage aus dem zdf-politbarometer
und sehen da folgendes ergebnis wenn wir
das uns gerade noch mal gemeinsam
anschauen wollen also die union liegt
bei 22 prozent die spd kommt auf 25
afd und fdp liegen jeweils bei elf linke
6 grüne 17 prozent das ist jetzt im
vergleich zur vorwoche nahezu identisch
lediglich die linke einen prozentpunkt
verloren wie bewerten sie das als
wahlvorstand zwei wochen vor der wahl
ja das ist ja erstmal ein bisschen
beruhigen auch dass wir mal eine umfrage
sehen in der sich jetzt nicht dramatisch
viel verschiebt zugleich ist es
bemerkenswert weil die bewegungen die
wir in den vergangenen wochen gesehen
dann wirklich groß waren weil es auch
immer noch viele menschen gibt die
unentschlossen sind insofern ist es
keine selbstverständlichkeit dass sich
jetzt also eine stabilisierung ein
schild aber das ist passiert und es
bleibt bei der situation die spd steht
gut da die cdu/csu stehen auf historisch
niedrigen werten aber passt es
eigentlich am ende für koalitions
bildungsprozesse bedeutet bleibt
tatsächlich völlig offen vieles ist
möglich insofern stehen uns immer noch
zweieinhalb wochen oder gute zwei wochen
bis zum wahltag bevor aber auch sehr
spannende tage und wochen danach bieten
diese unklarheit welche koalition sich
bilden eigentlich dann aufgelöst wird ja
soweit die erste einschätzung von ihnen
professor es vielen dank schon mal dafür
in der tat ist ist spannend die zahlen
sind sehr eng zumindest was union und
spd miteinander betrifft auch bei den
grünen weiß man noch nicht genau wie es
da weitergeht wir sprechen gleich weiter
dann über diese aktuellen entwicklungen
befassen uns jetzt aber erstmal mit dem
parteitag der csu in nürnberg und sind
sehr froh dass wir sprechen können mit
manfred weber das machen wir gleich
wären zunächst rein in die rede die der
frisch gewählte wiedergewählte
csu-parteivorsitzende gehalten hat
nämlich markus söder er mit dem ergebnis
von 87,6 prozent gerade bestätigt worden
wir hören mal rein wie er versucht die
delegierten seiner partei noch mal ja in
die richtige stimmung für die letzten
zwei wochen des wahlkampfes zu bringen
die umfragen sind nicht ausreichend
liebe freunde und es droht tatsächlich
ein politischer erdrutsch das erste mal
in der geschichte der bundesrepublik
deutschland könnte eine rot rot grüne
regierung an die macht kommen und ich
sage euch und das ist die aufgabe dieses
parteitages wir wollen keinen
linksrutsch in deutschland und für alle
journalisten zum mitschreiben wir wollen
armin laschet als kanzler abend statt
olaf scholz oder annalena baerbock liebe
freunde lasst uns kämpfen last zeigen
dass wir es noch können
geschlossenheit bei uns geschlossenheit
mit armin laschet aber auch
entschlossenheit wir wollen wahlen
gewinnen ich habe schon mal gesagt ich
habe keinen bock auf opposition liebe
freunde
kein bock auf opposition sagt markus
söder und da ist er uns zugeschaltet
manfred weber wir sprechen mit ihnen
sind sehr froh dass sie die zeit für uns
haben profilierte europapolitiker
stellvertretender vorsitzender auch
ihrer partei einen schönen guten abend
nach nürnberg herr weber
hallo herr söder also warnt vor einem
linksrutsch aber das muss man sagen tut
er ja schon seit längerer zeit in den
aktuellen umfragen scheint diese warnung
noch nicht so verfangen zu haben muss
man befürchten dass die union ihr pulver
schon verschossen hat im wahlkampf
nein ganz sicher nicht der parteitag ist
für uns als csu in bayern und auch für
die union insgesamt der richtige
zeitpunkt sich spüren hier dass die
partei
einsatzbereit ist wir wollen überzeugen
wir wollen gewinnen wir wollen mit
unseren themen überzeugen und es geht um
eine richtungswahl aus unserer sicht wir
wollen es den menschen auch aufzeigen um
was es geht beispielsweise
steuererhöhungen versus steuersenkungen
stabile haushalte beispielsweise bei der
inneren sicherheit hinter unseren
polizisten stehen und bei der
fragestellung umwelt einen weg mit der
wirtschaft finden und nicht gegen die
wirtschaft wir wollen überzeugen und
dafür werden wir jetzt in den letzten
zwei wochen wie viel sorge bereitet
ihnen denn die aktuelle sonntagsfrage
wir haben die zahlen ja gerade gesehen
die messe ist noch nicht gelesen wir
sehen in den umfragen auch und das werde
auch durch die wissenschaftler bestätigt
viele menschen überlegen sie schauen
sich die politiker an sie schauen sich
die angebote an die wir als demokraten
den menschen in deutschland machen und
sie werden dann ihre selbstbewusste
entscheidung fällen und ich glaube diese
wahl wird auf den schluss- metern
entschieden es ist knapp viele sind
unentschieden und die wollen wir jetzt
gewinnen für bürgerliche politik und ich
finde wir sollten als union auch jetzt
stück weit frustriert wir sollten auch
deutlich machen dass dieses land nach 16
jahren unionsführung mit angela merkel
gut dasteht wirtschaftlich geht es uns
gut sozial haben wir viel gestaltet und
wir sind geachtet in europa und in der
welt da draußen und das wollen wir in
die zukunft führen der csu
generalsekretär markus blume er hatte im
vorfeld gesagt mit söder stadt mit
laschet stunden der jetzt besser da was
die zahlen angeht allerdings muss man ja
auch sagen die werte für die csu in
bayern im moment auch denkbar schlecht
gerade mal 28 das sind für die
verhältnisse dort ja sehr magere zahlen
woran liegt das denn
wir sitzen in einem boot wir werden
gemeinsam gewinnen wir werden gemeinsam
verlieren was wir machen da gemeinsames
angebot als cdu und csu für deutschland
und deswegen gibt es nur einen einzigen
blick nämlich den blick nach vorne
morgen wird die lasche beim csu
parteitag zu gast sein er ist unser
gemeinsamer kandidat wir wollen mit
ihnen gemeinsam gewinnen und die bürger
wissen sie bekommen cdu und csu als
gemeinsames angebot um unser land in die
zukunft zu kommen markus söder hatte im
vorfeld gesagt wenn es noch eine chance
gibt den trend zu brechen dann an diesem
wochenende das heißt es im umkehrschluss
wenn das jetzt nicht gelingen sollte
heißt es dann für die union man kann
dann die bemühungen in den nächsten zwei
wochen einstellen
natürlich natürlich nicht wir werden bis
zu den letzten metern miteinander werben
und kämpfen aber klar ist dass dieser
dieses wochenende wichtig ist der
csu-parteitag sendet ein signal der
geschlossenheit der union familie wir
wollen gemeinsam das armin laschet
nächster bundeskanzler wird ein
brückenbauer ein politiker der
zusammenführen kann dass der kanzler
wird und wir werden beim tri eltern am
sonntagabend bei der öffentlichen
debatte dann auch erleben dass armin
laschet die besseren konzepte für die
zukunft dort also insofern werden wir
gemeinsam überzeugen das ist unser
ansatz wir haben user fragen die ich
ihnen gerne noch weiter reichen würde
christian hartwig per mail fragt wie
sieht denn die csu die spitzen von herrn
söder in richtung herrn lasche glaubt
die csu wirklich dass dieses gebaren
förderlich ist wie sehen sie das
wir wollen gemeinsam überzeugen und bei
markus miller ist vielleicht manchmal
schwierig weil er eben sich auch
beworben oder um die spitzenkandidatur
dass manches auf die goldwaage gelegt
wird seine aussagen heute waren
kristallklar wir wollen gemeinsam das
wir union in deutschland in berlin
führen dass wir mit armin laschet ins
kanzleramt ein sind es war klare
botschaft von ihm heute deswegen es gibt
keine diskussion in dieser richtung mehr
wir wollen gemeinsam gewinnen dort
letzte fragen von mir was macht sie
zuversichtlich dass armin laschet die
trendwende jetzt noch schafft in den
letzten zwei wochen
es wird uns gelingen weil armin laschet
jetzt mit argumenten in den industriell
gehen wird und morgen beim parteitag in
der csu der starke position vertreten
wird wir wollen mit atom momenten über
gewinnen wir wollen mit der sache
gewinnen und ein ist es mir für europa
wichtig wenn wir linke regierung kriegen
vielleicht sogar mit der ex kommunisten
in der verantwortung dann wird es in
europa eher zur weiteren vertiefung der
spaltung führen zwischen den neuen
ländern in mittel osteuropa und dem was
eine berliner regierung bringt und
deswegen mag vielleicht manchmal dann
die unionspolitik des brückenbauers
zusammenführen etwas ja ich fast sagen
nicht so spannend herüber kommen aber
sie ist für europa wichtig sie ist
europa notwendigen brücken bauen brücken
bauen brücken bauen zusammenhalten der
gesellschaft und europas und dafür steht
armin laschet manfred weber war das für
uns fraktionsvorsitzender dvd
stellvertretender parteivorsitzender der
csu vielen dank nach nürnberg danke
schön für das gespräch schönen abend
ich bin da geht nicht
soweit also die einschätzungen von herrn
weber und weiter geht's bei uns direkt
mit dem analytiker kann man sagen mit
professor thorsten faas werten
garmischer mit ihm gesprochen von der
fau berlin jetzt haben wir gerade herrn
weber davor auch noch mal kurz herrn
söder gehört herr professor fast wie
bewerten sie denn die ersten eindrücke
vom csu parteitag
wir sind zwei wochen vor der wahl es
geht jetzt um die eigenen mitglieder die
wahlkämpferin wahlkämpfer zu
mobilisieren auch zu motivieren denn es
gibt noch eine menge zu holen und das
haben sowohl markus würde in der rede
aber gerade auch manfred weber im
gespräch
ja auch deutlich gemacht das ist jetzt
durchaus noch was zu holen gilt dass man
jetzt nicht versagen darf aber man
merkte auch an den sätzen die so fallen
es ist noch nicht entschieden
die linken haben noch nicht gewonnen hat
markus söder gesagt die sorge ist schon
groß dass die wahrscheinlichkeit dass
sie gewinnen doch größer ist als man es
vielleicht vor ein paar wochen oder
monaten gedacht hätte ja das ist ja
sowieso ein interessantes phänomen dass
wenn man das vor ein paar wochen alles
gefragt hätte oder das hat man ja auch
getan die werte eben ganz anders waren
wie erklären sie sich diesen doch
bemerkenswerten turnaround gerade was
das verhältnis jetzt von union und spd
angeht
ja es ist unglaublich viel im fluss wir
haben zum ersten mal eine bundestagswahl
bei der keine amtsinhaberin antritt wir
haben sehr sehr viele themen schon
erlebt in den letzten zwei jahren corona
die flut afghanistan derzeit reden wir
vergleichsweise viel über gerechtigkeit
die koalitionsfrage ist offen und das
alles vor dem hintergrund dass menschen
nicht mehr in dem maß wie früher stabile
parteibindungen haben dass die
volksparteien nicht mehr in dem maße
selbstverständlich integrieren wie das
früher mal der fall gewesen ist und wenn
dann eben auch situationen dazu kommen
denken wir in armin laschet denken wir
ein annalena baerbock in der sich die
öffentliche meinung sehr schnell ändert
sehr schnell auf der wind heftig von
vorne kommt naja dann rutschen die
images dieser personen nach unten und
wenn personen wichtig sind die höheren
immer auf den kanzler kommt es anderen
rutschen eben auch die partei werte nach
unten das ist aber eine dynamik die wir
das ganze jahr über schon sehen insofern
wäre es jetzt falsch sagen das war es
jetzt definitiv es ist vorbei nein da
ist noch eine menge zu holen aber ein
momentum das liegt derzeit sicherlich
nicht bei der union sondern eher bei der
spd und alleine schon diese tatsache was
tut die union jetzt um da rauszukommen
macht ihr das leben schwer weil es
letztlich dann so ein wenig panisch
wirkt so als würde sie alles nur
versuchen um da rauszukommen das wirkt
dann nicht unbedingt inhaltlich
getrieben und damit auch nicht unbedingt
überzeugen ja wir wollen wenn wir weiter
sprechen gerade vielleicht auch noch mal
die zahlen zur grundlage nehmen die die
kollegen vom zdf politbarometer erhoben
haben bei uns natürlich auch nachzulesen
auf zdf.de
gucken wir vielleicht gerade noch mal
auf die persönlichen werte wen hätten
sie dann am liebsten als bundeskanzler
wenn wir uns das vielleicht gerade auch
noch mal anschauen wollen denn da sind
die zahlen ja auch relativ klar da
schauen wir uns das an und sehen dass
immerhin 48 prozent bei olaf scholz ihr
kreuz machen würden 21 ballast 16 bei
bernburg 15 sagen weiß nicht jetzt ist
ja die frage ist ist oft zu hören es
werden parteien gewählt und nicht
kandidaten aber wie wichtig ist dann
trotzdem die zustimmung der akzeptanz
der person des spitzenkandidaten der
kandidatin
erst einmal ist das nicht in stein
gemeißelt sondern genau das ist ja auch
gegenstand des wahlkampfes worum geht es
überhaupt manche sagen auch den kanzler
kommt das an andere sagen nein es geht
um klima andere sein nein es geht um
stabiles regieren und das alles kann ja
gleichzeitig auch in den köpfen von
menschen präsent sein dass sie sagen
olaf scholz ist ein guter kanzler aber
das thema ist ein grünes aber irgendwie
hat die union in den vergangenen
fünfzehn sechzehn jahren auch alles in
allem gut regiert und ich kann aber am
ende nur ein kreuzchen machen und das
heißt am ende ist es letztlich auch eine
frage was sind denn die entscheidenden
kriterien oder was ist das entscheidende
kriterium dass menschen anlegen wenn sie
in der wahlkabine stehen weil das nicht
klar ist ist es so spannend trotzdem
muss man sagen wir haben in diesem war
ja sehr sehr viel über personen
gesprochen habe annalena baerbock auch
armin laschet waren für viele
wählerinnen und wähler auch
vergleichsweise neu und damit war ihr
image eigentlich auch nicht in dem maße
aus definiert wie wir das vielleicht von
einer kanzlerin merkel oder eben auch
einem vizekanzler scholz kennen und
entsprechend beweglich waren die
zustimmungswerte da ging s aber so steil
nach oben aber eben auch sehr sehr steil
nach unten und in einer situation
nachfolge merkel ist es nicht relevant
sondern da geht es natürlich auch um
personen es geht um das wichtigste amt
im in unserem land dazu sagen personen
spielen keine rolle dass das wäre
einfach nicht haltbar und entspricht
nicht der realität tom tailor schreibt
uns über youtube laschet ist ein kämpfer
er dreht es noch meiler philipp ist
einfach mal ein paar kommentare vor er
ich bin enttäuscht dass sie laschet
stadt söder genommen haben ich wähle
sonst immer links und grün aber diesmal
hätte ich cdu gewählt gegen baerbock ok
offenbar eine klare persönliche
ablehnung selina wiederum laschet null
chance söder hätte es noch mal reißen
können das mag dahingestellt sein also
das ist natürlich auch das was aus der
csu zu hören es werden es für ihn schon
gesagt generalsekretär markus blum er
meinte auch man stünde jetzt besser da
wenn man sich für söder entschieden
hätte das weiß man natürlich nicht aber
die frage die sich jetzt ergibt ist was
muss denn der union jetzt gelingen was
muss armin laschet gelingen in den
nächsten wochen um dann nochmal die
trendwende hin zu bekommen was was muss
er jetzt versuchen zu zu schaffen
er ist da wirklich in einer ganz ganz
schwierigen situation und die csu
manfred den ja noch zusätzlich in eine
sehr schwierige situation wenn jetzt
gesagt wird eigentlich ist dieses
wochenende der csu parteitag aber auch
das morgige trocknet riege der drei
kanzlerkandidaten quasi schon die letzte
chance und da muss er jetzt liefern das
weckt natürlich erwartungen die er
eigentlich kaum wird einlösen können man
muss auch sehen ein plötzlich ganz
anders agierende armin laschet auch das
wäre ja nicht glaubwürdig er muss er
sich treubleiben
er darf nicht zu offensiv zu aggressiv
sein als kanzlerkandidat der union denn
er muss der kanzler format bewahren also
das ist ein sehr schmaler grat in
erfinden muss was du beim letzten trade
show gesehen haben ich denke das werden
wir auch beim trial am sonntag sehen ist
natürlich der versuch in die offensive
zu kommen scholz gerade auch
herauszufordern der ja nun sein starker
gegenspieler geworden ist aber es wird
wir haben beim ersten trial gesehen das
perlt an scholz ein stück weit ab unter
der flasche dann auch nicht überziehen
aber trotzdem er ist jetzt quasi der
herausforderer und entsprechend offensiv
attackieren werden erleben dann schauen
wir uns vielleicht gerade auch nochmal
weil das auch teils unseres
politbarometer ist die bewertung der
koalitionsmodelle an es gibt ja
verschiedene koalitionen die da jetzt in
frage kommen könnten auch das wollen wir
uns gerade noch mal anschauen und wie
beliebt oder unbeliebt die sind
zumindest bei den befragten aber das ist
durchaus repräsentativ also spd grüne
und fdp 41 schlecht zu 33 finden dieses
bündnis gut also rot grün rot dann cdu
csu grüne und fdp jamaika
52 schlecht 29 gut spd grüne und linke
die ampel 56 prozent schlecht 28 prozent
finden das gut spd grüne linke natürlich
eine förderung also sie haben gemerkt
ich hab nicht vertan ist wie die grüne
und fdp das wäre die ampel natürlich
richtig und dann spd grüne und linke
pardon also das dann wiederum
rot-grün-rot so ist es richtig dass das
schlechteste oder von der beliebtheit
her schlechteste bündnis jetzt aber
trotzdem die frage an sie warum schließt
denn scholz eine koalition mit den
linken nicht aus könnte ihm das nicht
helfen
ja natürlich das ist zunächst mal etwas
was gerade verschenkt von seiten der
union man rückt es immer sehr sehr stark
in den vordergrund diese angst vor dem
linksbündnis was macht das mit
deutschland was macht es mit europa und
die stabilisierung die wir bei der union
sehen könnte auch damit zusammenhängen
dass es einfach gelingt damit zumindest
eigene anhänger erst mal bei der stange
zu halten zugleich muss man sehen wir
haben eine ein maß an
unübersichtlichkeit gerade bei den
koalitionen dass wir so wirklich nicht
kannten eigentlich war nach
bundestagswahlen mehr oder minder immer
klar welche koalition gebildet werden
kann und welche sich dann auch
entsprechend bildet diese zeiten sind
wirklich passé
nach dem neuesten politbarometer könnte
es sogar wieder für eine große koalition
unter spd-führung reichen aber sie sehen
die drei optionen auf dem bildschirm die
eine mehrheit hätten es gibt ja sogar
noch andere die auch eine mehrheit
hätten und das alles macht es für uns
wählerinnen und wähler ganz ganz
schwierig und daran zu orientieren
koalitionsverhandlungen zu beeinflussen
das können wir eigentlich nicht sondern
wir können eigentlich nur sagen naja wir
stärken die partei die den kanzler hat
den wir mögen die das thema hat dass wir
für wichtig halten und der rest das ist
dann ein bisschen mehr vorsehe da muss
man gucken worauf sich die parteien
verständigen aber das ist schon viel
viel unübersichtlichkeit was wir da
sehen da ist der versuch des
linksbündnis jetzt an die wand zu
projizieren tatsächlich ein versuch ein
bisschen orientierung zu bieten aber
scholz wird das nicht ausschließen weil
das für ihn natürlich eine machtoption
ist ist auch beschlusslage der spd
keinerlei bündnisse auszuschließen und
er löst es im moment eher dadurch dass
er eben inhaltliche kriterien formuliert
die eingehalten werden müssen aber
gleichwohl wir können uns sicher sein
wir werden in den kommenden zwei wochen
sehr sehr viel darüber reden auch wenn
es häufig sehr unbefriedigendem ergebnis
sein wird warum ist rot grün rot
eigentlich so relativ unbeliebt ist das
misstrauen gegen die linke nach 30
jahren wiedervereinigung mehr als 30
jahren immer noch so groß oder hat das
andere gründe
die gründe die angeführt werden sind
natürlich immer außenpolitischer natur
und auch das erinnert uns daran dass der
politische raum über den wir letztlich
hier in einen solchen wahlkampf auch
entscheiden ja nicht nur
innenpolitischen fragen und fast auch
nicht nur ökonomisch wirtschaftliche
fragen sondern auch fragen von kultur
identität wer sind wir eigentlich wer
gehört zu uns aber eben auch die rolle
deutschlands in der welt zum gegenstand
hat und da gibt es eben die großen
konfliktlinien zwischen der linken und
eigentlich den allermeisten anderen
parteien mit blick auf die nato vor
allem und das ist natürlich etwas wenn
man in die deutsche geschichte schaut
was eigentlich so zu den er so genannten
außenpolitischen konstanten gehört die
werden hier herausgefordert dagegen kann
man dann natürlich auch polarisieren und
zuspitzen aber gleichwohl ein in
mancherlei im sozialpolitischer sicht
sind die überschneidungen zwischen rot
grün und rot also der linken durchaus
groß sprechen gibt es da auch bei
sozialpolitiker in durchaus präferenzen
für dieses für dieses koalitionsmodells
aber man muss auch sehen die mehrheit
wäre stand jetzt sehr sehr knapp und
auch das wird natürlich olaf scholz sich
sehr genau überlegen ob er sich dann in
die hände jedes einzelnen linken mdbs
begibt den herr land für eine mehrheit
braucht aber es bleibt spannend und das
ist wirklich eine der großen neuerungen
dass diese koalitions lage so sehr
unübersichtlich geworden ist und
keinerlei orientierung mehr bietet
interessante zeiten für uns als
journalistin aber natürlich auch für sie
als politikwissenschaftler und offenbar
auch für unsere user ich wohl gerade
noch mal ein paar kommentare ab prinz
naif schreibt mir kommt es so vor als ob
alle medien seit wochen wissentlich die
cdu schlecht reden und scholz
unfairerweise pushen darüber gab es in
der tat auch diskussionen ob er zu gut
weggekommen ist zum beispiel nach dem
ersten trial aber von der gezielten
manipulation lässt sich da wohl
schwerlich sprechen
ich weiß es nicht aber ich würde es
jetzt erwarten und vermuten das ist
natürlich auch so ein stück weit ein
narrativ das sehr häufig
interessanterweise eigentlich von allen
parteien geäußert wird dass man
irgendwie das gefühl hat man kommt
schlechter weg als die anderen mann wird
kritischer betrachtet als andere
insofern glaube ich es ist einfach teil
unseres freiheitlich demokratischen
systems das medien das presse natürlich
dinge kritisch betrachtet nicht nur
sozusagen positiv lobhudelei an am start
hat das tut weh manchmal das wirkt dann
manchmal auch unfair wenn man da
vielleicht im feuer steht aber wenn man
sich die einzelnen sachen die der user
vielleicht implizit anspricht anschauen
dann gab es natürlich letztlich auch
immer grund für diese berichterstattung
die ist ja nicht vom himmel gefallen das
muss ein kandidat dann schon auch sich
selber anziehen diesen schuh ja sie
sprechen an wahrscheinlich auch die
fehler die sowohl herr laschet als auch
herbert frau werbung natürlich gemacht
haben im wahlkampf die ja auch in
wittlich diskutiert worden sind tim
thaler schreibt über die spd im
steilflug ich verstehe die welt nicht
mehr die tun ja alle so als wenn die spd
nicht zur jetzigen regierung gehört und
die guten sind das ist ja dann auch ein
interessantes phänomen natürlich sind
sowohl die union als auch die spd
momentan regierungspartner warum gelingt
es scholz vermeintlich besser irgendwie
das jetzt in dem wahlkampf den er führt
zumindest mal nicht als makel an sich
haften zu lassen
wer tatsächlich ist das ein sehr
spannendes phänomen weil wir ja auch
schon wahlen erlebt haben bei dem gerade
diese rolle als juniorpartnerin für die
spd sich wirklich als sehr sehr
nachteilig erwiesen hat und und ihr ein
wahlkampf praktisch unmöglich gemacht
hat allerdings eben gegen eine kanzlerin
die auch kaum angriffsfläche geboten hat
die ist jetzt weg ist es unklar wer ist
eigentlich gerade der amtsinhaber die
amtsinhaberin ist es die union als
partei im moment ist es eher stolz als
kandidat und es gelingt ihm ganz gut so
einen mittelweg zu finden einerseits zu
zeigen ich habe klammer auf im gegensatz
zu meinen herausfordern vielleicht große
erfahrung auf der bundesebene auf der
internationalen bühne aber wenn ich an
der spitze der nächsten regierung stehe
dann habe ich ja nicht mehr die union so
als als bremsklotz für linke
sozialdemokratische politik am bein dann
können wir noch viel mehr erreichen das
ist ein relativ da gibt es ja nicht um
fakten ob das an jeder stelle so stimmt
aber es verfängt diese mischung aus
konnte das auch sehr schön sehen in
denen in den sogenannten townhall wo er
auf bürgerinnen und bürger getroffen ist
wo er immer wieder diese erzählung hatte
ich weiß worum es geht ich habe
erfahrungen wir haben schon viel auf den
weg gebracht aber es kommt noch viel
mehr und das scheint ganz gut zu
verfangen und als nachfolgemodell merkel
tatsächlich gut zu funktionieren
gucken wir gerade nochmal auf die drei
möglichen koalition wir hatten jetzt
gesprochen schon über rot grün rot aber
gucken uns vielleicht noch mal die
zumindest relativ von den dreien gesehen
beliebteste anders dass spd grüne und
fdp also die ampel da sagen zwar auch
mehr schlecht als gut 41 zu 33 aber für
wie wahrscheinlich würden sie denn ein
zusammengehen dieser drei halten also da
gibt es ja nun auch zitate im vorfeld
auch zum beispiel von händler der sagt
ihm fehle die fantasie wie würden sie
das einschätzen
nun ja die fdp hat vor allem eine grün
geführte ampel sehr früh doch sehr
deutlich eigentlich ausgeschlossen diese
rot geführte abend unter scholz da war
man doch etwas offener man muss ja auch
sehen es gibt für all diese modelle
letztlich vorlagen auf der länder ebene
wir haben eine ampel koalition in
rheinland pfalz für die ja auch volker
wissing der generalsekretär fdp auf
bundesebene lange zeit stand der aus
rheinland pfalz kommt eigentlich kann er
diese option dann auch als person nur
schwer als völlige unmöglichkeit
darstellen aber wir merken schon auch an
diesen sehr mäßigen zustimmungswerten
das ist nichts wo leute verbrennen das
ist für die fdp natürlich schwierig rot
grün die ja durchaus auch so ein
gemeinsames lager bilden die auch die
regierung 98 05 gebildet haben dieser
diesen beiden parteien quasi zu einer
mehrheit zu verhelfen
das ist gut um in eine
verhandlungsposition zu kommen aber
trotzdem ist es schwer der eigenen basis
zu vermitteln insgesamt sind diese
ganzen koalitionsdiskussionen noch mal
wir haben die wert her gesehen gerade
wirklich keine gewinner diskussion
sondern das ist immer sehr sehr sehr
sehr sehr unbefriedigend denn natürlich
wollen wir wissen welche regierungen uns
nach dem 26 september regiert aber
realistischerweise werden wir es vor der
wahl einfach nicht erfahren weil es
nicht im strategischen interesse eines
akteurs jetzt ist bestimmte dinge
auszuschließen anderes anzupeilen das
schmälert einfach die
verhandlungsposition das muss man leider
so kühl an der stelle sagen vielleicht
können wir der stelle gerade unsere user
mal fragen ob ihr dann schon abgestimmt
gehabt denn das ist ja auch ein ganz
interessanter aspekt und das knüpft an
das an was sie gerade gesagt haben die
frage nämlich wie sicher die
wahlentscheidung ist die wird ja auch
ganz interessant verantwortet auch im
politbarometer nämlich mit 59 prozent
sagen ja und 41 prozent sagen nein meine
entscheidung ist noch nicht gefallen
also wie gesagt gerne auch an uns
schreiben wenn ihr schon wisst was ihr
vorhabt aber das ist wiederum auch
interessant im vergleich zu vorherigen
werten also auch bei der letzten
bundestagswahl da war zwei wochen vor
der wahl die korrigieren sie mich wenn
ich immer diese entscheidung schon viel
deutlicher gefallen wie ist das jetzt zu
erklären dass das relativ volatil noch
ist
ja da war die messe gelesen könnte man
so etwas salopp formulieren und
entsprechend zäh waren dann auch die
beiden letzten wahlkampfwochen nein das
ist dieses mal ganz anders und die frage
ist was passiert mit diesen menschen die
in großer zahl jetzt noch nicht
entschieden sind einige davon werden
nicht zur wahl gehen auch das muss man
muss man erwarten auch wenn das
natürlich schade ist andere werden sich
verteilen auf die parteien insgesamt
aber die spannende frage ist ob es
tatsächlich so ein moment um gibt oder
ob es dabei bleibt dass gerade die
unentschlossenen am ende doch in eine
bestimmte richtung tendieren das haben
wir schon gesehen wenn wir in sachsen
anhalt denken in diesem jahr oder auch
baden-württemberg rheinland-pfalz da
haben sich trends und prozesse die sich
schon längere zeit vor dem wahltag
angedeutet haben dann zum wahltag hin
beschleunigt und das ergibt ja auch sinn
ich meine warum sehen wir diese trends
weil es eben gerade für bestimmte
parteien gut läuft weil auch dieses in
anführungszeichen es läuft natürlich
eine signalwirkung hat auch die
unentschlossenen die werden sich schon
überlegen warum läuft denn gerade für
die warum wenden sich menschen
bestimmten personen und parteien zu
sofern kann man erwarten dass dieser
trend sich dann vielleicht doch
fortsetzen aber nochmal es wäre jetzt
vermessen zu sagen wir haben ein jahr
von unglaublicher dynamik erlebt aber
jetzt zwei wochen vor der wahl da ist es
auf magische weise vorbei es ist noch
nicht entschieden und das ist eigentlich
eine schöne sache denn es geht ja um
eine ganze menge am 26 september achten
die menschen denn jetzt mehr auf fehler
die kandidaten machen könnten oder
achten sie mir auch noch mal bewusst
positive signale die vielleicht gesetzt
werden was was ist jetzt entscheidend
aus politischer sicht
wir machen uns nichts vor die meisten
argumente sind ausgetauscht wir kennen
das personal wir kennen die themen der
ein oder andere wird jetzt beim tri l
noch mal die chance nutzen und auch die
chance wertschätzen die drei ganz
unmittelbar miteinander vergleichen zu
können in ihrer persönlichkeit auch in
ihrem positionierung aber trotzdem es
geht jetzt eigentlich nur noch darum
wirklich um um harte kärrnerarbeit
dranzubleiben am wahlkampf noch mal von
tür zu tür zu gehen was ja inzwischen
ein sehr beliebtes wahlkampfinstrument
in deutschland auch ist und wenn man
noch mal die brücke zum csu-parteitag
schlägt da haben wir ja genau das
gemerkt jetzt einfach auch die eigenen
leute weiter zu motivieren diesen ja
auch unglaublich fordernden wahlkampf
zeitlich physisch fordern wahlkampf
bereits am ball zu bleiben nicht
aufzugeben auch da kann man noch mal
sagen auch da haben die umfang natürlich
einen effekt wenn man das gefühl hat das
bringt doch alles gar nichts verwehen
laufe ich denn hier von tür zu tür na
dann motiviert es nur in sehr
bescheidenem maße vorsichtig formuliert
also auch das ist so ein indirekter
umfrage effekt den man aber glaube ich
nicht unterschätzen sollte experten
rechnen mit bis zu 50 prozent
briefwähler innen welche folge hat das
denn dann eigentlich die sind ja dann
zumindest für ihr hat den wandel da ihr
kreuzchen gemacht haben aber vielleicht
für den sport gar nicht mehr erreichbar
ja das ist vollkommen richtig als
beobachtung was wir aber sehen ist das
sehr sehr viele briefwahlunterlagen
schon verschickt worden sind aber es
gibt auch so ein paar städten hinweise
leipzig beispielsweise listet es sehr
detailliert auf das noch gar nicht so
viele briefe alle unterlagen
zurückgekommen sind also sind welche
schon zurückgekommen klar und für diese
menschen ist der wahlkampf zumindest was
die eigene entscheidung betrifft damit
gelaufen
aber man sollte nicht so weit gehen zu
sagen weil wir dieses jahr ein
rekordwert an briefwahl haben führt es
dazu dass schon wochen vor der wahl
praktisch zwei drittel der stimmen
abgegeben sind das ist nicht so aber es
verschiebt natürlich trotzdem diese idee
eines eines einzelnen wahltages hin zu
so einer wahl phase die sich potenziell
über mehrere wochen verlagert das ist
für parteien herausforderungen auch das
in ihre planungen einzubeziehen
aber es ist es nimmt auch sozusagen die
eine oder andere wahlkampf logik die wir
kennen am ende noch mal zwei drei tage
alles zu geben das muss man dieses mal
weiter spreizen was die effekte betrifft
danach hatten sehr gefragt ganz schwer
einzuschätzen weil wir einfach dieses
mal.mehr und damit auch vermutlich
andere briefwählerinnen und briefwähler
haben als bei früheren wahlen so dass
wir die befunde von früher gar nicht so
leicht übertragen können rechnen sie
noch mit überraschungen
es kann immer gerade auch in so einem
trial wenn millionen zuschauer vor dem
bildschirm sitzen einen fehler passieren
der dann auch in der
nachberichterstattung noch mal sehr
prominent diskutiert wird also ja da
kann schon noch was passieren der
anderen seite gerade wenn wir jetzt noch
mal ein anlass stolz und berbalk denken
das sind erfahrene politiker und
politiker die ago momente die sie machen
die präsentieren sie täglich mehrfach
auf den marktplätzen dieser republik
also es müsste jetzt wirklich schon eine
ganze ganze menge passieren dass ich da
noch so richtig was dreht aber die
unentschlossenen die bleiben natürlich
da die werden sich entscheiden und
insofern ja es ist durchaus noch
spielraum drin ist ist ja auch ein
knappes rennen wir hatten gefragt ob die
entscheidung schon gefallen ist bei
unseren usern ich sehe jetzt noch nicht
viele reaktionen so viel hat man
schreibt noch nicht gewählte noch unklar
aber laschet als kanzler möchte ich
partout nicht gut andere sehen das
bestimmt anders und auch laschet hat ja
nochmal sie haben es angesprochen die
chance eben rtl auf sich aufmerksam
beziehungsweise auch schon mal die
zuschauer von ihm dann eben auch
einzunehmen diese chance wird er sich
mit sicherheit nicht entgehen lassen
wollen ich danke ihnen ganz herzlich für
das gespräch professor thorsten faas war
das für uns von der fau berlin ein und
schönen abends und ich danke auch
unseren usern natürlich wie immer und
verweise gerne neben auch nochmal auf
das gerade angesprochen trier das ist
nämlich auch bei uns im live stream zu
sehen mit analysen mit einer
entsprechenden vor und nachbereitung
natürlich wie sich das gehört das ganze
dann am sonntag ab 19 uhr 45 bei uns in
stream viel spaß damit ich hoffe ihr
schaltet ein und wir sehen uns demnächst
wieder einen schönen abend und
einstellungs wochenende distanz